ازدادت وتيره الاتهامات لايران بارسال
جنود من الحرس الثوري للقتال الى جانب
نظام الاسد
اتهامات تقف دائما امام النفي الرسمي
الايراني لاي تورط مباشر في سوريا
نتوقف مع هذا الموضوع لنناقشه من زاويتين
لماذا الاعتراض على التعاون الايراني مع
سوريا طالما ان البلدين مرتبطان باتفاقيات
ثنائيه وان كان شكل المساعدات الايرانيه
هل تستطيع طهران الاستمرار في تامينها
لدمشق لفتره طويله
السلام عليكم
منذ دلاعه ثوره السوريه لم يتوقف حديث
المعارضه السوريه والغرب عن الدعم
الايراني للنظام السوري اخر هذه الاشارات
ما ذكرته صحيفه
من النخبه والحرس الثوري والمئات من جنود
المشاه الى سوريا لدعم نظام الاسد الصحيفه
الامريكيه استندت الى تصريحات قائد في
الحرس الثوري وان قالت انها لم تتحقق منها
من مصدر مستقل قد تختلف التقديرات بشان
حجمي وشكل المساعده الايرانيه للاسد لكن
الثابته ان دعما ايرانيا يصل بانتظام الى
شرايين النظام
باعتراف طهران نفسها
ليس بالانحياز السياسي والاعلامي فقط
وانما كذلك بارسال المال والسلاح والخبراء
والمقاتلين تقف ايران الى جانب حليفها
الاستراتيجي في الشرق الاوسط نظام الرئيس
بشار الاسد وهو يكافح للبقاء في وجه ضربات
معارضين لحكمه هذا ما نقلته جريده
عن موقع الكتروني تابع للمعارضه الايرانيه
نسب لقائد في الحرس الثوري الايراني يدعى
سالار ابنوش تصريحا قال فيه ان ايران تخوض
حربا متعدده الابعاد في سوريا عسكريا
وثقافيا الموقع الايراني اضاف ان ايران
قامت بالفعل بارسال المئات من نخبه وخبراء
ومشاه الحرس الثوري الى سوريا ليقدم الدعم
التدريبيه واللوجيستيه والمخابراتيه لقوات
نظام بشار الاسد في قرار عجل بتنفيذه
تفجير دمشق الذي اودى بحياه قاده من الصف
الاول في النظام السوري وعجل به كذلك اله
الكبير على دمشق واشتباكات حلب التي اظهرت
اشتداد شوكه المعارضه السوريه المسلحه لم
يتسنى للتاكد من هذه المعلومات من مصدر
مستقل خاصه وانها بدت على مسافه من مواقف
ايرانيه تعودت عدم اخفاء مساندتها للنظام
السوري بالتوازي مع نفي اي تدخل ميداني
الى حد الان مع التاكيد في كل مره ان
طهران لن تتخلى عن دمشق التي وصفتها
بالضلع الاساسي في مثلث ما يسمى معسكر
الممانعه بالنسبه للجيش السوري الحر لا
تضيف له هذه المعلومات جديدا فقد سبق
لمقاتليها اختطفوا من قالوا انهم عناصر
تابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني جاءت
للمساهمه في القتال الدائري في سوريا الى
جانب النظام السوري وهو الامر الذي نفته
طهران تماما في رد وجهت مثله لتصريحات
امريكيه تحدثت هي الاخرى عن طلوع ايران
وحليفها حزب الله في قمع معارض الاسد في
جدل يصف في عمقه حده استقطاب اقليمي ودولي
محوره الاحداث الدمويه الجاريه في سوريا
معنى من لندن
الخبير مدير الشبكه العربيه العالميه
للدراسات غسان ابراهيم وفي الاستوديو
العميد اركان حرب صفوت زياد الخبير في
شؤون العسكريه والاستراتيجيه وسينضم الينا
بعد قليل امير الموسوي الخبير الاستراتيجي
في الشؤون الايرانيه سيكون معنا من طهران
اهلا بضيوفنا جميعا لو بدانا من لندن
والسيد غسان ابراهيم
عندما تكرر المعارضه بشكل شبه دائم تقريبا
اتهامات لايران بالوقوف ميدانيا عسكريا
عمليا مع النظام الاسد على ماذا تستند
يا سيدي عندما نقول ذلك نحن لا نتهمهم بل
ندينهم من افعالهم واقوالهم حقيقه الجميع
سمع من ايران انها اعتبرت ما يحدث في
سوريا هي معركتها المقدسه الجميع سمع من
ايران انهم قالوا ان النظام الاسد هو انهم
وكذلك بادرهم الغزل اليوم وزير الخارجيه
النظام المعلم عندما قال ان امريكا هي
اللاعب الاساسي وما تفعله في سوريا انما
هو محاوله وضع حد للنفوز الايراني
والايرانيون منذ اليوم الاول اعتبروا
الثوره السوريه انها مؤامره بينما حتى
النظام نفسه في فتره من الفترات اعترف ان
هناك حقوق مشروعه للشعب السوري كما انه
الجميع يتذكر ان من الاسابيع الاولى خامن
استعرض عضلاته وقال انه سوف يرصد خمسه
مليارات دولار لهذا النظام اي انهم من
اليوم الاول وضعوا ادخلوا ايديهم ورؤوسهم
في شؤون الشعب السوري اي واليوم يسمع
التحصيل رهيبه التي تصدر هذا من حيث
الموقف السياسي لكن عندما تتهم طهران
بانها تدعم نظام الاسد على الارض بجنود
وخبراء وغير ذلك ومعدات على اي اساس يجري
هذا الاتهام
الاساس يثبته الارض لدينا 48 معتقل من
الحرس الثوري دخلوا بشكل غير شرعي الى
سوريا لانقاذ هذا النظام فقام ابطال الجيش
السوري الحر باب القاء القبض عليهم ونفسها
ايران اعترفت انهم من الحرس الثوري ولكن
قالت انهم من المتقاعدين نحن نتساءل الشاب
الذي عرض الايراني للحرس الثوري الذي عرض
ومعه بطاقه من الحرس الثوري هل هذا عمره
اليس واضح انه عمره تحت الاربعين ام ان
هناك رفاهيه للشعب الايراني في ظل هذا
النظام الارهابي الذي يمنحهم التقاعد في
سن مبكر هذه احد الدلائل 48 دليل اصبح بيد
الجميع بالاضافه اننا نشاهد جميعا المجازر
التي ترتكب ترتكب في اغلب الاحيان بعد
زيارات يقوم بها مسؤولون ايرانيون يلتقون
مع بشار الاسد ولاحظوا هنا ان اخر
اجتماعين بين الايرانيين وبشار الاسد لم
يكن فيها الا بشار الاسد فقط لم يكن هناك
اي سوري اخر هذه يعيد الى مثلا الديكتاتور
حافظ الاسد كان ندا في صداقته مع
الايرانيين بينما هذا ليس الا حقيقه يعني
اجير لدى الايرانيه
سيد ابراهيم بالنسبه لايران بالنسبه
لايران تعتبر ربما طبيعي جدا ان تقف مع
نظام صديق وقف معه هو ايضا في حربها ضد
العراق وهنا نسال امير الموسوي الذي انضم
الينا الان من طهران عندما
يقال عن دعم ايراني لسوريا هذا الموقف ليس
سرا عمليا كيف يتجسد
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اولا لا بد من الاشاره الى ما قاله ضيفك
من لندن اعتقد انه
يغالط نفسه كثيرا عندما يتهجم على ايران
بهذه الصوره
الاعلاميه في الحقيقه التي لا تستند الى
اي واقع عندما يسمي زوار ابرياء دخلوا
سوريا بصوره شرعيه وعندما يخرج من مرقد
السيده زينب سلام الله عليها
ويختطفوا بهذه الصوره الغير الانسانيه ولا
انسانيه يسميهم جنود ومسلحين واتوا لقتال
للقتال في سوريا اين ساسلتهم اين مقاومتهم
اين كل هذا اذا انا اعتقد ان هناك نوع من
المزايده الاعلاميه في هذا الامر ايران
منذ البدايه تقول ان الازمه لابد ان تحل
سلميا وسياسيا ولاحظنا والجميع شاهد خلال
18 شهر كل الاجراءات وكل التفاصيل قد نفذت
في الازمه السوريه ولن تفلح يعني كل هذا
الدعم السلاح والمال وكذلك الاعلام كله
وظف
لتدمير سوريا ولن يحصل شيء
عفوا طهران عندما تقف مع دمشق وهي تعلن
ذلك ليس سرا ماذا قدمت يعني فقط النوايا
الحسنه والمواقف السياسيه لابد انها قدمت
اشياء ملموسه ما هي
نعم ايران وقفت الى جانب مطالبات الشعب
السوري الحقه
ووقفت الى جانب الحكومه السوريه في
اصلاحاتها لكننا لاحظنا منذ البدايه
وقفت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبعض
حلفائها وبعض الدول الاوروبيه للحيلوله
دون الوصول الى تفاهم سياسي بين الفرقاء
في سوريا والان نرى ايران تجدد هذه الدعوه
مره اخرى عبر قمه عدم الحيااز عسى ولا على
ان ترى
الاجواء طيبه في هذا المجال اسمح لي انت
تتحدث عن تحليل الموقف السياسي
لايران طهران تقف مع دمشق هذا واضح لكن لا
يمكن ان تكون تقف معها فقط
بالاعراب عن التضامن لان لابد ان يكون شيء
عملي مساعدات ماليه اقتصاديه لنقول سلاح
او رجال كما تقول المعارضه ولكن صديقك
وجارك وحليفك في محنه فقدت تبيعه مواقف
سياسيه غير غير غير منطقي يعني
لا ليس فقط سياسيا انا لم اقل سياسيا
ايران دعمت احتياجات الشعب السوري من خلال
تزويد الكثير من المؤسسات المدنيه في
والاقتصاديه في سوريا عبر ارسال وقود
ارسال الدواء ارسال امكانيات غذائيه ارسال
اجهزه طبيه كل هذه المساعدات وصلت الى
سوريا ووصلت الى الشعب السوري وان كانت
بصعوبه لسبب انه الوضع غير مواتيه هناك
حتى حتى الدقيق والحنطه وكثير من القضايا
التي والغاز يعني انابيب الغاز التي وصلت
الى البيوت الى مناطق بعيده وكذلك يعني
المستشفيات المتحركه كل هذه الامدادات
الانسانيه وصلت الى سوريا وان كانت بصعوبه
لكن انا اعتقد ان لدى ايران علاقات
استراتيجيه مع الحكومه السوريه في سبيل
التصدي للمخططات الصهيونيه والامريكيه في
المنطقه لمده اكثر من ثلاثه عقود ليس انا
هذا انا اعتقد هذه التسريبات ربما تهدف
الى شيئين اساسيين الهدف الاول هو تقويه
موضوع ايران فوبيا يعني الان ترى الدول
الغربيه وخاصه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
انها فشلت للحيلوله دون ذهاب القادم
الحيازه والهدف الثاني
لتخويف لتخويف الرئيس مرسي سموه
امير قطر ان لا يذهبوا الى طهران النقطه
الثانيه هو ربما ايجاد مسوغ لدعم الجماعات
المسلحه من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لان تقول ان الحرس الثوري موجود
هناك اذا علينا ان نساعد الجماعات المسلحه
بالسلاح ولذلك
اذا كانت المساعدات تسمح لي فقط على
المقاطعه اذا كانت المساعدات بالاساس هي
اقتصاديه ومرافق مثل ما ذكر سيد موسى
حضره العميد هل تعتقد بان
بلد مثل سوريا يستحق يحتاج الى دعم ايراني
عسكري ميداني لوجستي يعني اعتقد ان جيش
ربما اليوم اكثر من 17 شهر يقاتل لابد ان
يحتاج الى دعم خارجي يعني يكفي حتى يعني
على الاقل حتى ما ذكر عن الوقود او المواد
المحركه او الاساس ان مواد الطاقه التي
ربما الان يؤخذ غالبها من السوق المدني
الداخلي في سوريا ويذهب الى تشكيلات
القتال ما كنت ترى طائرات تقلع وما كنت
ترى اليات مدرعه ايضا ربما تستخدم الارض
وربما هذا يذكرني انه في في عام 73 كان
هناك حديث وقبلها عن كيف انشه ايران ربما
وهو نظام السابق كيف انه امد يعني اله
الحرب الاسرائيليه بوقود طائرات ووقود
للاليات المدرعه الارضي اذا هذه نقطه ربما
وجاء ربما جاءت الثوره الايرانيه لتفتح
عصر جديد ولكن المشكله الكبيره ان هناك
علينا ان نتذكر ان هناك دعم خارجي ما لا
يمكن هذه العمليه الكبيره التي اطاحت
براسها امنيين كبار ونجد هذه الثلاثه ما
زالت في اداره العمليات ولكن الجيش السوري
ليس جيشا بسيطا هو جيش تقريبا اكثر من 40%
من ميزانيه الدوله تذهب له على امتداد
سنوات جيش مهيا لحرب في اي وقت حتى وان
كان نظريا ليس عمليا فبالتالي ان يخوض
معركه بهذا الطول مع مع عصابات مسلحه بين
قوسين ليست مهمه كبيره
لحرب غير تقليديه وهناك اذا تصورنا هناك
نصيحه او خبره او ربما امداد بشيء ما من
يعني من الجانب الايراني
سيوفر له الكثير هذا الجيش لم يتعود ولم
يتدرب على قتال مدن وهذا الجيش لم يتعود
وليست بين نظم يعني انا عندما اوقع
اتفاقيه انا بوقع اتفاقيه ضد عدوان خارجي
لكن عندما يكون هناك شان داخلي هذا امر
اخر ويحتاج الى مفاهيم اخرى نعم على كل
ايا كان الدعم الايراني لسوريا سواء
بالمعنى المدني او العسكري الى اي مدى
يمكن ان تواصل طهران فيه هذا ما سنتطرق
اليه بعد فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا معنا
اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد نزلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها طبيعه الدعم
الايراني المقدم لنظام بشر الاسد سيد امير
الموسوي بغض النظر عن طبيعه ما تقدمه
طهران طهران ايضا لديها اوضاعها الداخليه
وهي ايضا تتعرض لعقوبات هل يمكن لطهران ان
تواصل هذا الدعم
للاسف فقدنا صوره السيد امير الموسوي
سنعود اليه
في هذا الموضوع تحديدا سيد غسان ابراهيم
هل تراهنون عن ان الاوضاع الداخليه ربما
في طهران لن تسمح لها بان تستمر مع هذا
النظام في سوريا الى ما لا نهايه
نحن نشعر حقيقه بالاسى على الشعب الايراني
الذي حول العشرات السنين يضحي مقابل هذا
النظام الذي كان دائما يستخدم نفس الاسلوب
الذي يستخدمه النظام الاسدي المقاومه
والممانعه
وكشفتهم وفضحتهم
كشفت القناع عن النظام الايراني عندما
قالت انها الايرانيين او النظام الايراني
حقيقه هناك تحالف ابدي مع اسرائيل وانهم
كانوا دائما يدعون الخطر الاسرائيلي من
اجل استغلال الشعب الايراني وارسال هذه
الاموال لمشاريعهم الخارجيه لذلك نشاهد ان
المشروع الاسدي والمشروع حزب الله ومشروع
مقتدى الصدر ومالكي وغيرهم هم على حساب
الشعب الايراني كذلك الحال في سوريا اموال
الشعب السوري كان يصرفها هذا النظام بحجه
المقاومه والممانعه هذا المحور المماوع
اصبح من طهران الى القرداح نحن نقول لهم
الجبهه اذا كنتم تريدون الى هذه اللحظه
والسيد الموسوي يقول عن الصهيونيه والى ما
هنا نقول لهم الجبهه في الجولان ليست في
حلب وليست في دمشق فتوجهوا الى هناك
فارسلوا حرسكم الثوري الى هناك وارجله
واظهر بطولاتكم
هذا الدعم انا اعتقد والوقوف الى جانب
الشعب السوري والحكومه السوريه الممانعه
والداعمه للمقاومه سيكون مستمر ما دامت
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه قائمه وما
دام الصراع بين المقاومه والكيان الصهيوني
قائما انا اعتقد ان هذا لا يمكن التفريط
فيه وما يحصل الان من هذه التسريبات ومن
هذه الاقاويل انا اعتقد ان ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه نعرف ان مؤسساتها غير
مستقله حتى العلميه وما يقال ان مؤسسه
علميه قرات ودرست واصدرت دراسات معمقه
علميها هذا كلام غير صحيح انه
يصلك الامريكيين نترك الامريكيين
والاسرائيليين قليلا ايرانيا في الداخل
نتذكر جميعا بانها كانت بعض المظاهرات في
وقت من الاوقات في طهران كانت تعرب عن
التبرم من دعم ايران لحماس ولحزب الله
ولغزه وقالت لنا اهتم بشؤوننا هذا الضخ
المستمر حتى وان كان من الطحين والوقود
مثل ما ذكرت قبل قليل هل يمكن ان يستمر
الان طوال هذا الاشهر وقد يستمر لاشهر
اخرى على حساب قوه المواطن الايراني
قوه المواطن الايراني يوزع حسب المصلحه
العليا
للحركه المقاومه للصهيونيه وهي خطر على
المواطن الايراني كذلك الكيان الصهيوني
يهدد ايراني يوميا بضربها وتدميرها
وازالتها فلذا انا اعتقد الشعب الايراني
واعي بهذا هناك اصوات اخرى موجوده لسبب
حاله الديمقراطيه في ايران وطبعا هذه
الاصوات موجوده وربما ستستمر لكن الاكثريه
القاطعه والاكثريه
الاكثريه العامه في ايران تؤيد هذا التوجه
وما يوم القدس العالمي وخروج عشرات
الملايين في طهران وانحاء المدن الاخرى
والقرى والارياف الا دليل على ذلك ان
الشعب الايراني متوجه لهذا الاتجاه ويدعم
هذا الاتجاه فلذا نعتقد ان ما حصل من
تسريبات هذه هذا اليوم او امس اعتقد بما
انهم لاحظوا ان المبادره الايرانيه بدت
تلوح الى الافق وهناك تاييد كبير من
قيادات عدم الانحياز وان هناك توجهات حتى
من المعارضه السوريه والحكومه السوريه
اللي قبول هذه المبادره وما ورسائل اتت من
تركيا وروسيا وقطر والسعوديه تاييدا لهذه
المبادره هم بادروا بهذا الامر لافشال هذه
المباراه ولكن ليس يعني سيد موسى وهنا
اسال السيد غسان ابراهيم في لندن اليس
الذهاب بعيدا ايرانيا في دعم نظام بشار
الاسد يستثني امكانيه سقوط هذا النظام
وبالتالي فها فهو يلعب الجميع الاوراق مع
جهه واحده هل لديكم شعور بان هذا الامر
يمكن الاستفاده منه بالنسبه للمعارضه
يا سيدي ايران حقيقه تلعب على
خيارين او سيناريوهين مطروحين لديها على
على الطاوله الاول تحاول ابقاء هذا النظام
كما قال مسوي بكل الخيارات بشكل مستميت
لابقائه الى اللحظه الاخيره ولكنها بنفس
اللحظه تنظر الى فتره ما بعد هذا النظام
لانها ادركت وشاهدت خصوصا ما بعد معركه
دمشق ومعركه حلب وبدات تجاهر جهارا نهارا
بمساعدتها لهذا النظام بدات تفكر بما بعد
بشار الاسد من خلال اعاده هيكله ميليشيات
بشار الاسد النظام الاسدي على نفس الطريقه
اللبنانيه اي اعاده انتاج حزب الله او حزب
الشيطان ولكن في سوريا الى المرحله
المقبله ليكون خنجر في خاطره سوريا
المستقبل فهم دائما وبالعوده الى ما كان
يتفضل به ويقول عن قضيه الصهيونيه
والامبرياليه كلما تحشر اي مسؤول ايراني
عن اي شان
جوهري لديهم مباشره ليقول لك صهيونيه
وامبرياليه مقاومه وممانعه هذه هي العباره
العباره المشروخه التي
مل منها ملت منها الشعوب الشعب السوري
والشعب الايراني وهذه العبارات كلما
كرروها كلما اكدوا وانهم متامرين على
شعوبهم ومتضامنين كانظمه هذه الشعوب
اسمح لي فيما يتعلق بقدره ايران على
الاستمرار هناك العميد اركان حرب في نهايه
البرنامج
تعتقد بان ايران قادره على ان تبقى مع
نظام بشار الاسد الى الاخير لا اعتقد اذا
تغير الموقف وحدث تدخل دولي نحن الان
سنواجه مسرح عمليات على اذا اقيمت مناطق
عازله او مناطق حظر جوي لن تستطيع ايران
ان تفعل شيء في مسرح عمليات على مسافه
اكبر من قلب من على مسافه اكثر من الف
كيلو متر ربما من حدودها ودعني اقول لك ان
على الايرانيين ايضا ان يتنبهوا ان هناك
حامل الطائرات ثالثه جون ستانس تتجه الى
الخليل ليصبحوا ثلاث حاملات وهنا خشيه
كبيره للغايه انه اذا ما تورطت ايران ربما
في عمل ما قد يكون هذا مبرر لانشغالها
ومبرر اكثر لشن عمليه ربما ضد برنامجها
نوما بمعنى هذا ان عليه ان تعيد
الاستراتيجيه ونحن كثيرا ربما ما كنا نقف
مع البرنامج نوسم الايراني وندعمه كثيرا
والزميل من طهران يشهد على هذا لكن
المشكله الكبيره انهم ربما قراوا الموقف
في سوريا بصوره مخالفه اياد وكافه الثورات
العربيه عدا هذه الثوره او الربيع العربي
في الدمشقي ولكن الاهم ان مسرح العمليات
كبير ان القدرات محدوده وربما وربما ايضا
اذا زادت التهديدات على ايران فيما يتعلق
لتلقيها ضربه ربما
تنطوي على نفسها
ان تجري حساباتها الاستراتيجيه بدقه وبدقه
كبيره للغايه الامكانيات العسكريه
الايرانيه محدوده وعليه ان تتذكر ان حتى
روسيا الاتحاديه لن تغامر بالتدخل اذا
ربما ما بدات مثل هذه العمليات قيمه
الاستراتيجيه انها تعطيك احيانا قدر ان
تعيد تقديم تقديراتك بصوره كبيره ونتمنى
لايران ان شاء الله ان تتفهم ماذا يجري في
سوريا
وان تدرك انه ربيع عربي جديد وان المساله
ليست مرتبطه بنظام على الاطلاق شكرا جزيلا
لك العبيد سوف تزايد الخبير في الشؤون
العسكريه والاستراتيجيه شكرا ايضا لضيفينا
من طهران كان معنا امير الموسوي الخبير
الاستراتيجي في الشؤون الايرانيه وكان
معنا من لندن غسان ابراهيم مدير الشبكه
العربيه العالميه للدراسات بهذا نكون قد
وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ماوى الخبر في امان الله